guys uh so we should be back and
hopefully there'll be some guests
remaining on the channel listening in to
part two of this special interrupted uh
interview with uh sir Roger Penrose and
Dr Stuart hammeroff and I don't see it
live there it is now we're live there's
one person watching good that's at least
more than could be expected so let me
um let me continue so where were we we
were discussing the uh
but uh yeah we're having fun
um
I was saying
uh uh yeah so we were talking about
um
uh yes the role of of the collapse of
the wave function and I mentioned I
would like to know if let's say that
there isn't a Copenhagen interpretation
um is not correct uh and there is sort
of an everettian World many worlds
phenomenon could such a thing
be could microtubules play a role in it
in other words you need to collapse if
you don't have Oracle R do you can you
have a theory of quantum mechanics that
doesn't feature State reduction in the
same way as it does in the standard
Copenhagen interpretation do you get uh
Consciousness or this Consciousness not
arise in some sense
well the view is that all Co-op by
definition is orc which means
orchestrated and the or well it spells
or but it means objective reduction so
that theory simply doesn't occur I mean
it's just
it needs the collapse of the wave
function and I've never understood how
you can have many worlds I mean it
doesn't really explain conscious
experience or anything like that because
if all the Alternatives the quantum
Alternatives coexist
why are we only aware of one of them
right and maybe it doesn't have anything
to say about that at all it just doesn't
make to me to my I hate to say this
because there's so many philosophers in
Oxford who are strong supporters of many
worlds so I should I should shut up
I you you've got to have things where
where there's just one world that
survives and the other ones die off in a
sense but the Alternatives yes for
orco-r you have to have that
so um is it more uh is it more an
objection to uh to the many World Series
and that it doesn't seem to accommodate
Consciousness or is it is it you know
sort of more evidentiary for you know
for the standard or Copenhagen type uh
wave collapse uh Etc in other words if
God tells you there are many worlds uh
what how would you react I mean would
you say no that can't be because there's
no consciousness in such a state
well it doesn't live comfortably with
Consciousness because it doesn't explain
why conscious experience only
experiences one of these worlds and even
worse than that and this was the thing I
always objected to it's all right you
could imagine that for some reason each
person experiences one world but why do
we all of us seem I mean well all my
friends called drifting off into other
worlds and why do they seem to be
companions with Consciousness just like
myself and seem to be inhabiting the
same world that I have
so it's not it doesn't make any sense to
me so why philosophers take it so
seriously I find this very strange
but I think you see there's two wedded
to the
the equations that we know you see the
equation the Schrodinger equation
Schrodinger was absolutely clear and
pointing this out his own equation does
not explain the world we see
the world we see has to have some
another ingredient which is in some
sense or other
the wave function collapses so you get
one alternative and not all is possible
alternatives coexisting I mean they do
if they're small enough
so that's the puzzle you have to have a
theory in which okay yeah when you're
talking about small things
and you're talking about you know
particles or atoms or
um
molecules as long as they're small
enough
they seem to follow the schroding
equation so you need to have a theory
which tells you when they get big enough
they don't follow the schroding equation
and the idea is here that there's a
scheme
which tells you
how long these superpositions can exist
and if they're very tiny it's more or
less longer than the edge of the
universe but if they're sizable it might
be microsecond
so you've got to sort of balance this
right so that it comes about so that
these collapses happen with structures
about the right size and that's that's
the question to make the theory work
you've got to make sure that these
numbers come out right and the numbers
are how long the collapse takes
come from a very pretty clear equation
like it was due to nice Yoshi actually
he had the idea before I did but he
didn't have the motivation that I did
and his version is different from mine
but you it's certainly the same idea you
it this depends on gravity so you have
to have a theory which involves
the ideas of Einstein's general theory
of relativity which is the theory of
gravity and curved space-time and all
that and you try to fit that together
with quantum mechanics
and many people regard it as the one of
the profound problems of physics is to
what they call quantum quantized gravity
so they're think of imposing the rules
of quantum mechanics on gravitational
Theory but to me that's going the wrong
way because it doesn't deal with the
problems the inherent in quantum
mechanics namely this problem of
superpositional States not persisting I
mean we don't see in the world we
observe so you need a theory which is
put right and the claim is that
Einstein's general theory of relativity
when appropriately combined with quantum
mechanics will do that for you which is
the other way as gravitising quantum
mechanics rather than quantizing gravity
so is it true that you wouldn't have
Consciousness in minkowski space I mean
would it be impossible without
gravitational force I mean obviously
you'd have matter you'd have a
rep sum gravitating uh but is it is it
impossible then to have Consciousness in
a in a region that's either perfectly
flat has no matter or is otherwise free
from perturbations
well yeah that would be the claim yes
certainly the Orca Theory claims you've
got to involve gravity so if you had
things that didn't involve gravity and
the space time is flat it's got to
involve Einstein's theory not just
gravity in the Newtonian sense
um and you've got to have that so I
would agree yes if you if your
assistants were
too small or something to to affect the
gravitational field significantly which
they would not be conscious
and when you guys started this
conversation 30 years ago did you ever
think there'd be experimental tests both
ongoing that seemed to support and some
that seem to contradict some of your
results to it did you think that besides
what you do where you put people to
sleep which I point out I do that every
time I give a lecture you know to my
students I I do the same as you Stuart
so don't feel too you know I'm not a
real doctor okay but um but did you ever
think outside of the brain you know the
medical world that we do physics
experiments on Consciousness or is this
totally you know a surprise to you
no I I was hoping for it certainly and
uh I I'm not a physicist but I was I
studied a lot of physics in undergrad
and have followed it along and and what
uh what we've found is that uh uh
because of the aromatic ranks the pie
resonance where the where the conscious
Quantum stuff is happening that Quantum
Optical effects occurred and uh what
we've uh been hearing about uh here at
this conference are uh reports from two
different Laboratories one at Princeton
with uh Greg scholes and arachara where
they did uh tryptophan fluorescence
lifetimes in microtubules and tubulin
and found that if you you zap a
microtubule with a UV Photon there's a
signal that propagates uh 50 nanometers
or so along the microtubule that's a
Quantum process and if you then add
anesthesia it goes away or you dampen it
and we did it with two different
anesthetics one a gas although we did it
in the liquid phase and then the other a
soluble liquid anesthetic accommodate
the gas was isofluoride and and that
that's being written up now and and
should be a very nice paper uh our
cholera was the uh postdoc I did a
superb job and the other is in a lab at
University of Central Florida and the
lab of RSD dogarayu who is a Quantum
Optics guy who got into biology and and
he's been looking at a slightly
different Quantum Optical effect in
microtubules called delayed luminescence
where you you hit the microtubule with a
photon at a much lower energy Photon of
visible Photon and what you see there is
that the microtubule actually uh get has
what's called delayed luminescence it
gives it gives off photons for up to a
second or or longer which is a very long
time and Quantum Quantum effects and
also in his experiments the anesthesia
took away the these delayed luminescence
which we think may be a phenomenon
called super Radiance that there's a
sub-radiant state and it leads super
radius audience which is the prolonged
State and that seems to go away with
anesthesia what we want to do next is to
do those studies in the gas phase
so that we can have the microtubule in a
chamber and a Plexiglas chamber let's
say with air and then we introduced uh
with the gas Inlet a little anesthesia
and see if the delayed luminescence
super Radiance goes away and then when
you when you blow away the gas and uh
anesthesia and go back to air that it
comes back like a patient going to sleep
and waking up that's that's what we want
to see and then uh we will do it for
different anesthetics which have not
different known potencies in putting
people and animals to sleep and if the
the potency in in dampening the super
Radiance matches the potency in putting
humans and animals to sleep I think we
have a darn good argument that that's
the molecular correlate of Consciousness
and I have to say Brian that that that
these experiments are you know
preliminary but they're very prominent
missing they go in the right direction
and I think they're far more than any
other Theory Of Consciousness has really
uh because we're we're not quite at the
mechanism we're not at Roger's objective
reduction but we think these Quantum
Optical effects lead to the objective
reduction and how that happens is a
whole nother story that maybe we'll talk
about when you talk about the uh the
controversy because that that's the
relationship yeah yeah well I want to
get to that in a second but uh one thing
you know came to me as a terrifying
thought I I heard um I got a genetic
test recently uh it's just part of a
checkup and it came back that I'm 99.7
uh genetic garbage but besides that I
say nobody's perfect nobody's perfect
but um but it also said that there um
that I respond to Anesthesia in other
words I you know that I don't have
Inhibitors or I I ca I don't um you know
reuptake them or I forget exactly that
you'll be able to correct me in about
two seconds uh but there are people the
doctor told me that don't that you know
will have anesthetic applied anesthesia
applied and they'll be fully conscious
and in other words there are people you
can't turn off genetically they don't
they have a predisposition can you
explain what that is and then what if
could these types of people be sort of a
control in other words obviously
conscious but not responding to
Anesthesia is a typical you know normal
member of the society would or
population would can you explain what's
going on here well I'm not aware of
people being totally immune to
Anesthesia there are there are genetic
conditions where people are resistant
and need more but anesthesia always wins
at least in my experience if we give
enough they'll go to sleep and one of
the genetic uh traits that is resistant
to Anesthesia is red hair so redheads
require more and so we have read a
patient red hair redheaded patient we
give them a little bit more no big deal
another category of patients that is
resistant to Anesthesia are people who
are taking the anti-cancer drug taxol
which stabilizes microtubules and they
require more anesthesia so uh those are
two examples of people being resistant
to Anesthesia but I'm not aware of
anybody being totally totally resistant
ah I got it
um good uh so Roger we we heard recently
uh some results from an experiment that
was supported partially by the
foundational questions initiative this
took place in Grand Sasso which is
normally I think of as a particle
physics laboratory deep underneath the
dolomites I believe it is in Italy not
far from Rome and there are many
experiments down there Xenon experiments
Dark Matter detection experiments
um first of all can you explain the
experiment why was it put there and what
does it have to do with either
bolstering or or criticizing uh orc or
well I should explain that
um
the idea was to test an effect which
people believed or these these people
believed should arise from a state
reduction theory like mine now the thing
is it depends on a formula which tells
you how long
a superposition between two states will
last which is actually due not to me but
to Elias to Yoshi and he had this idea
before I did I independently came across
the same formula uh using ideas from
based on general relativity whereas I
don't know quite where he got the ideas
from first so this was something in
common between his
theory of State reduction in mind and
when I say it's Tech reaction I mean the
collapse of the wave function
now
the thing is that in his version
you would expect a certain effect of the
substance would be heated but
spontaneously so if you have a material
which is isolated as best you can from
the rest of the world it would slightly
heat up spontaneously by itself just a
little tiny bit and the argument for
that is that all the time you have
superpositions in the body and these
superpositions become one or the other
all the time and when they become one or
the other
it sort of jumps and this means this
jumping is taking place all the time and
that has an effect that the body gets
heated
and they did this experiment to try and
test whether bodies would spontaneously
Heat
and they found that they didn't
now to me that's not the expectation I
have because although my model
had the same time scale as the Yoshis
did it's not the same Theory and it's
subtly rather different and I suppose
that's one of the reasons people didn't
take it into consideration
that it's I could it only I put it I can
put it in a rather strange way see
suppose the system
is in the superposition it becomes in
the superposition of here and there
so it's originally in one place then it
becomes in the superposition of two
places then after a certain point it
becomes one or the other
now if it does that the state sort of
jumps to one or the other but that's not
my view the view that I have is that
when it reduces to one or the other it's
as though it had been suppose it reduces
to this one rather than that one then
that means the state was in effect been
this one all the time
but this is a strange Theory because it
sort of looks at as though the world
behaves retroactively that is to say
it it you thought it was in a
superposition and then it becomes as
though it had been one or the other all
the time
and you have to try and understand how
that kind of retroactive Behavior can
make sense and doesn't allow you to send
signals into the past which would be
disaster if you could do that disaster
for physical Theory but it's the reason
that people didn't think of that idea
and I didn't think of it at first but I
had been thinking of it for you know a
few years I think two or three years
I've been taking that view seriously for
I think I was at one of Stewart's
conferences on consciousness
and it occurred to me that's the way you
had to look at it it's a little bit more
subtle because to make it make sense you
have to take the view that there are two
slightly different kinds of reality one
of them is what I call classical reality
and the other is what I call Quantum
reality and Quantum reality these
superpositions kind of persist as two
things at once and the classical reality
has got to be one or the other and it
goes back to that classical state of
being one or the other but it does it as
though it had been that all the time so
it's kind of retroactive in that sense
the decision of which to do comes later
but then it becomes as though it had
been that one all the time you have to
make that kind of crazy looking Theory
make sense
and the reason it's a you know people
don't think about it is because it's a
crazy looking Theory and you have to
realize why this Theory although crazy
looking
does actually make sense and doesn't
give you
you know communication with the past and
things like that it doesn't give you
sort of scientific nonsense it really
hangs together as a whole but I have
these different points of view
not even really fully together until a
paper which I wrote which should be
coming out sometime this month I gather
it's in a
in a volume of different articles by a
Chinese person called Shan GAO and it's
published by the Oxford University press
and Stuart has an article in it and I
have a separate article in it in this
article I do explain this point of view
and how you can have these two kinds of
reality and why it makes sense and and
Stuart there's some questions we're
taking from the audience and by the way
you can always ask questions for all my
guests I have Nick Bostrom coming up uh
Rogers uh colleague over there in Oxford
uh he's coming on Monday I have Bernardo
castroup coming on I've had Sabina
hasenfelder's episode is coming out she
did an interview with sir Roger for her
new book uh which is wonderful
existential physics comes out on Tuesday
so stay tuned also you can ask questions
on my YouTube channel or on my Twitter
account so there's some questions that
have come in and um and I want to start
taking some of them because I know you
guys it's getting late for Roger at
least
um Stuart people are asking about
psychedelics which are you know maybe uh
maybe the opposite of anesthesia in a
certain sense maybe they heighten
awareness in in certain ways is there a
role for these if you could arrange the
permissions to do it I know there are
people at Johns Hopkins Tim Ferriss is
famously leading a big study or funding
a big study for
um Stanford I believe is there a role of
psychedelics in addition to anesthesia
and Consciousness research yes
absolutely in fact we were discussing
that and we hope to do those experiments
uh they are tricky the prediction is or
my prediction is that they would have
the opposite effect and if you look at
the molecules uh LSD psilocybin DMT
their their aromatic Rings just like the
tryptophan very similar to tryptophan uh
inside the tubulin and so the these
electron uh Pi resonance orbitals that
are are fluorescent luminescent delayed
luminescent super Radiance all that kind
of stuff and so uh the prediction would
be that if you and and the other one
prediction is that they will bind
directly to microtubules now most uh
researchers will say well they bind to
the 5-ht2a receptor on the membrane
surface which they do but they're very
they're small nonpolar and they get
inside and should bind to to
microtubules directly and would increase
the quantum Optical effects that we saw
dampened by anesthesia seizure they
would go in the opposite direction so
that's uh that's a very important and
and we hope to show that
um can I can I address the uh the the
experiments that Roger was referring to
yeah please do because so they uh so
diashi is was one of the uh uh
investigators and they were looking for
radiation which would prove uh his
theory of or whereas Roger's theory of
or uh does not uh predict radiation and
so they did this experiment and over two
months to make a long story short they
found no radiation so uh what they could
have done I think is say well okay
diasio war was wrong a pen Reservoir is
correct but they didn't they didn't want
to accept that and what they did was
they said one of the parameters must be
wrong so the parameter that they looked
at is it has to do with with the nature
of superposition how can something be in
two places at once what does that mean
and of course Roger explained it by
saying by taking the equivalent
curvature in space-time geometry and
saying you have opposing uh curvatures
and when we did our our first paper
Roger and I in in 96 he said the first
thing we have to do is calculate you
know the superposition of the cognitive
protein be separated from itself and he
gave me the homework assignment of look
at it as the whole protein partially
separated from itself
uh look at at the level of each Atomic
nucleus in that protein separated from
itself totally side by side or look at
the nucleons the the protons and the
neutrons and he gave me the equations
and I and I did the algebra and it was
it was quite fun actually something
different for me and the launch the the
point was that the atomic nuclei
separated from the themselves by 2.5
Fermi lengths uh femtameters the the
radius of the carbon nucleus
um was optimal would would be the
dominant effect so we use that to
calculate the gravitational self energy
the protein and that gives us the time
of how many proteins you need to
collapse at a given time and we did
those numbers uh it came came out quite
sensibly actually so um anyway the after
the grand Sasso experiments the they
didn't want to accept that there was no
radiation so they said the these this
superposition separation that they you
apparently initially used our our value
of 2.5 fermis must be wrong and the lar
and and the lower that number and ours
was a small separation the greater the
radiation if if that's a bigger spread
then there would be no radiation they
said Well there must be a much bigger
spread so there's no no radiation and
they calculated this the smear Factor
quite literally they called it the smear
Factor R zero it would have to be on the
order of an angstrom five orders of
magnitude bigger than what we had said
and that's for the nucleus which makes
the the atom uh bigger than the almost
as big as a cell you know bigger than
the protein for sure it'd be a micron so
that didn't make any sense but uh but
that that made them happy because uh
then they they could account for the
lack of of radiation and but then they
kind of uh blamed us for some reason
they said that this was because Penrose
or didn't work and and they said and
they tried to develop their own version
of Oracle are based on diosi or which
they had
apparently just refuted so it didn't
really make any sense to me and I
thought the uh the
criticism levied at us in those papers
was was bogus and I think the the
headline in the uh fqxi uh uh press
release which said collapsing a leading
theory of the quantum origin of
Consciousness was unfair and completely
wrong
and right so Roger one question comes to
mind you know we think about
gravitational effects uh these you know
systems are are distributed uh in space
and time typically we think about uh the
the the fundamental object of space-time
being the metric and then from the
metric we can derive all sorts of
properties including expansion and so
forth but when we uh when we think about
um you know gravitational effects and
perturbations you know better than
anybody you're you know uh incredible
work on black holes which resulted in
you uh being the co-recipient in the
Nobel Prize two years ago
um that you know is involving massive
objects and and it's always you know
occurred to people you know that this is
this is sort of strange you know how do
gravitational perturbations manifest
themselves in such small scales as
microtubules and how are they how does a
microtubule distinguish the wild
curvature at a point you know in uh you
know it's some three-dimensional point
in my brain from something that's one
nanometer away from it or a few
nanometers away from it on the scale of
these microtubules I mean isn't the wire
curvature in classical gr isn't it a
smooth continuous analog function that
uh shouldn't vary so radically as to
initiate different conscious experiences
in other words how can the wild
curvature classical object how can that
influence you know quantum mechanics
well it's all part of that it has to be
all part of one Theory
I'm not completely sure I understand the
question I mean it's a question of
numbers and sure the gravitational
effects are extremely tiny and there's
no question about that I mean you could
you couldn't measure the the uh the
gravitational attraction of a microtuber
or something like that it's much too
small but then you you you have to if
you're looking at the collapse time
if you have to compare it with a with a
natural how do I put this
you see there's a natural unit
uh when you combine quantum mechanics
and gravity there's a natural units of
mass there's a natural unit of energy
some of these things are big and some
are small and you've got to get them the
right way so the for example the mass is
what's called a Planck Mass
which in ordinary scales is pretty small
but from a
point of view of a an
amoeba or something is huge so and then
you've got the plank energy which is
huge anyway that's that's a sort of
massive explosion
and then you've got the uh
the
uh plank time or what it's called which
is
you see the time you just have to get
these numbers in the right place that's
all so so when you're looking at a small
superposition
um sure the time scale for it to
collapse into one or the other could be
extremely long
certainly if it was a
hydrogen
um molecule or something like that well
that would be enormously long time
longer than the current age of the
Universe from The Big Bang to now so
it's it's much longer than that whereas
if you were looking
an amoeba I'd have to think about it you
see I think for an amoeba
I'm not sure certainly if you're if
you're thinking about uh you're getting
up to the scale where
the collapse times could be very rapid
if you had a grain of sand it would be a
ridiculously small fraction of a second
yeah
I would have to think I have done the
calculation
excuse me we've calculated that for
tubulence of course we know that
10 to the 15th tubulins will reach
threshold in 10 to the minus sevenths 10
minus seven seconds so uh roughly uh 10
megahertz uh frequency of these Oracle
or collapses in the brain
yeah that is a question of getting the
the parameters right no so you're never
quite sure
um whether you're simply putting the
object in a superposition of two places
you have to worry about the environment
it's in because it'll disturb the the
things around it and it also depends
what size it is too so so it's the same
mass but much smaller than the if the
effect would be quicker than if it's
that mass and bigger so you have to look
at all these factors and Roger when I
look back you know and kind of the
history of of general relativity
um I often bring up this fact which I
want to relate to computation and that's
artificial intelligence
um I think about Einstein and you know
as well as anybody what he called the
happiest thought of his life and that
was that
um if he was in free fall he wouldn't
experience gravitational field
uh and I want to ask you at what level
could a computer even in principle uh
experience both a happiness the happiest
thought of its existence A and B the
bodily sensation of free fall in other
words the emperor and the emperor's new
how could it even come close to this
Revelation which then led to gr and the
equivalence principle and everything
else in other words are you sanguine
about artificial intelligence this is
becoming conscious or how could they if
if so
well they wouldn't I mean my view is
that if you're just looking at
computation that doesn't involve
consciousness and this is certainly one
of the arguments I was making in the
emperor's new management going right
back to that
and it has to do with the fact that
um
computers don't understand anything
and the argument I'd used was the
basically goes to girdle
for some reason I always thought it was
obvious but other people have trouble
understanding it I didn't quite
understood this but you see I
when I was a graduate student in
Cambridge I went to three courses which
were nothing to do with what I was doing
I was doing pure mathematics algebraic
geometry and I went of course by Bondi
on general relativity and by Dirac on
quantum mechanics and you can see where
these people had a big effect on me but
the third third lecture I went to was of
course by by a band called Steen on
mathematical logic and I've been puzzled
by girdles theorem it seemed to show
there were things in mathematics you
couldn't prove right
and what it shows it's nothing like that
it's that if you have a certain set of
procedures that you could put on a
computer so they're they are basically
computational procedures or checkable by
a computer put it like that
so they're computable in that sense
then if they are your
all you can use to prove things you you
set these other rules that we we adopt
to prove things
then you what girdle shows it's an
amazing thing I also it's amazing here
is a statement
which you
by virtue of your trust in these rules
you can see that it's true
yet you can't prove it by the rules now
I found this absolutely amazing because
it means you're you don't use the rules
to understand things because how do you
know this thing is true you know it's
true but because you trust the rules
well it's you you if you're using the
rules then how do you know that using
the rules only gives you truth well
because you've looked at the rules and
you say okay they're all right yeah I
trust them
and what this girl Affair depends on is
not using the rules but your belief that
these rules actually work
and that depends on understanding the
rules so it seems to me it's what it
shows you is the quality of
understanding something isn't
constrained by rule so any kind
and that's positively the argument which
I've been using all the time and I and
to me girl showed that very clearly I
mean you have to bring in a few other
things afterwards but it's basically the
girl or theorem which says that
what the way we believe and what things
are true in mathematics is not governed
by a fixed set of rules
what were you we use understanding so
I'm saying outstanding is not a fixed
set of rules it's not algorithm it's not
a computer is not capable of
understanding so that's the argument
sorry that's a long no no I think that's
that's very helpful I guess you know
from my perspective physicists suffer
from mathematician Envy in that we don't
have an equivalent of girdles
incompleteness theorem for physics and
usually what people do is substitute in
paparianism you know falsification uh
dialectic and it doesn't seem to me to
fully adequately solve you know what is
properly held within the realm of of
physics and what is it lies without it
and what's incomplete or or you know not
about physics I mean obviously we don't
think physics is complete or completable
even uh but I guess you know the
question of of what you know doing the
best we can I know you're not such a
huge fan of popper in terms of uh you
know being the ultimate Arbiter of what
is scientific but lacking an equivalent
of girdle for physics and especially for
Consciousness
um so I I guess my question would be
what would it take to convince you uh
that that this is the true you know that
that Oracle R is the actual description
of what's going on uh in conscious
beings and and is there is there a
definitive as as popper with a crisp
experiment is there a crisp result
um again I know you don't believe that
popper is the last word but is there
some result that you'd like to see it
might be the experimental work of Yvette
Fuentes
um who I want to talk about uh in a
different one in a different
conversation but is there a possibility
to have a test Roger that would
definitively either prove you wrong
falsify you or or approve you and
Stewart you know are on the right track
well I don't know about definitive
because things in physics you know even
even when they're very well tested lots
of people still argue on otherwise you
know general relativity is now very very
beautifully confirmed theory in all
sorts of ways but there are still people
who even Einstein curiously enough uh I
think would have thought that it was
well I mean he said this that he didn't
think it was the I often wondered what
Einstein would have thought about my
theorem you see
gravitational collapsed as you
singularities
my guess is that he not that he wouldn't
have believed my theorem he would have
thought oh well that just throws you
general relativity is wrong
action I got from certain people
I know Bob dickley and when I visited
Princeton after this he slapped me on
the back and said you've done it you've
showed general relativity is wrong
you see
but I mean you see these things are
there wasn't anything definitive in
these experiments you just sort of
eventually have enough evidence to push
the majority of people in a certain
direction we're a long way from that now
and Stuart uh if you look at uh you know
kind of upcoming experiments well first
of all would either one of you like to
talk about the experiments of Fuentes
and all and her uh campaign to to uh use
uh Bose Einstein Comet sets what is the
what's the background behind it what's
the experimental motivation and uh when
can we expect results
well this is it's basically a an
approach to trying to test the or part
of okoa you see Oracle uh involves
the physical idea that the gravitational
influences give you a collapse of a wave
function
so you have a genuine formula for for
how long that's a formulas of the ocean
put forward but the different proposal
from that
and this hasn't yet been tested
experimentally
I've I had hoped that the bar Mister
would have done it by now because he was
doing an experiment which you put a
little mirror in a superposition of two
locations and I thought by now he
he looked as though he was going to have
the answer by now but I think he found
out that the
system was was needed to be cooled much
more than it had been so he doesn't have
a definitive answer
there are other schemes where people
have little tiny beats and they try to
put them in the superposition
but all these things are pretty far away
yet from from actually getting to this
point and for Eva Fuentes ideas is to
use boson sign condensates and she's an
expert on that area
I mean using these things for
gravitational wave detection was
wonderful wonderful idea I thought
but this is trying to use them
you can put a Boze sign content set this
is a
um you have to have it extremely cold
and these
um materials when they get very very
cold they behave in a certain sense like
big big States big Quantum system I mean
it means lack lack being a big atom in a
sense the wave function is very
macroscopic
and you have to get them extremely cold
and these things are
very good objects for getting them to
test if what is in two places at once
and will it become one or the other
this experiment is still a few years off
I'm afraid
um
well one reason she had a lot of
problems getting funding I think she's
got funding now at least for getting it
started
so it's you still have to wait five or
ten years before the set up it may well
be you can see effects earlier than that
there are ideas that she has in other
people have where you might be able to
test
before it actually becomes one or the
other the effects of it's potentially
going to become one or the other and
maybe the way we'll actually get the
test working
um
so uh there's a question from Cirrus K
Lee
um for both of you guys uh and that is a
quantum mechanical effects in
microtubules uh the the name microtubule
suggests yeah one-dimensional you know
tubes if you like uh Stuart you've
talked about matrices or Crystal and you
know sort of structures perhaps
um and now the question is is as much as
you know the dimensionality uh argument
you know is it is it possible to have
let me say this translating the question
perhaps um could you have a
two-dimensional uh conscious creature uh
or effectively you know uh
quasi-2-dimensional conscious creature
or is there something about three
dimensions of space plus one of time
that's crucial
uh I'd have to think about that I mean
Mike you could think of microtubule as a
two-dimensional object wrapped in a
cylinder
but the walls of that cylinder are a
lattice of individual proteins uh called
tubulin and there's about a billion
tubulins in every neuron
and as far as memory uh well let me
digress a little bit we don't really
know where memory is stored in the brain
people say in the synapses but the
proteins the makeup synapses are
transient and only last hours to days
and yet memories can last lifetimes and
uh microtubules seem to be the best
candidate for memory and each one of
those billion tubulins in a neuron can
be in one of many many different states
genetic ice ISO isoforms there's 22
different genetic forms in the brain
fewer and less less tissues each tubulin
can be post-translationally modified so
you have probably 20 30 possibilities
for each tubulin so it's I don't know uh
10 to the 9th raised to the 10 to the uh
30th or something like that an enormous
amount of information capacity in uh and
the and these microtubules are are
frozen and that's not frozen per se but
a cap so that uh this they they retain
their their lattice position they're not
they don't disassemble and reassemble as
they would in a Cell it needs uh needs
to uh Divide from mitosis
um interesting and of course the
question uh two Dimensions can give rise
to a three-dimensional hologram and
whether that's happened people have
suggested that and uh whether there's
interference leading that is a
possibility that's been raised for many
years going back to premium and came up
again at this meeting but um uh like I
said we found Quantum Optical effects of
microtubules that go away with
anesthesia and and that's uh
that's something uh you mentioned popper
let me let me go back uh
before we did this I I went I I went out
on a limb and uh Roger was not totally
pleased with me because I said if we
don't find Quantum Optical effects in
microtubules
or if we find them and they're not
inhibited by anesthesia then Orca War
would be falsified
[Music]
Roger said well you know it could be a
different mechanism other than the
quantum Optical effects I started to
worry a little bit and he said so you
put all our eggs in one basket or both
of our eggs in one basket so I kind of
uh was a little worried about that but
fortunately uh the experiments proved
exactly that we showed Quantum Optical
effects and microtubules and they go
away with anesthesia although we've only
tried aliquots of a few different
anesthetics we want to do it more
systemically hmm
um so I have another question from uh
you guys so in this uh context as I
mentioned I'm talking with Nick balstrom
I've talked to David Chalmers uh about
these uh issues of
um ultimate AI perhaps in the so-called
simulation hypothesis uh Roger are you
familiar with uh your colleague over
there on Oxford and his ideas about
super intelligence
you'll have to remind me what that is
sorry I I mean I think in some sense
it's it's a it's a conjecture that you
know with ever increasing Moore's Law
power uh eventually yeah there'd be a
super computer that could simulate uh
even a human brain even our human our
human experiences perhaps perceptions
what do you make of that argument I mean
I I would take it that you're a skeptic
but um uh how could how could something
even be reconciled is that does that
fall within the realm of physics or is
it pure philosophy
right I don't believe it but but then
you said you didn't think I believe it
um
it's just I mean you can fool people to
a certain extent I mean you can maybe
have a machine which I mean they're very
far from what's called passing the
Turing test even now you can make
machines as I said can you
talk to a thing and distinguish whether
it's a human being or or a very powerful
computer and that's what people refer to
as the Turing tests because I think
Turing considered this possibility being
rather considered that maybe you could
but the view that I'm holding is that
we're very very long way from that you
might fool people for quite a long time
questions how long can you fool them and
you realize it's just listen there's no
person we're a long way from it now I
mean you you these um devices which you
know supposed to keep you happy on the
phone
there's no I no there's they're nowhere
close to
exhibiting anything like a conscious
being there but you could imagine with
the future technology
um they could get pretty good at this
but that's not so surprising I mean you
can fool people
in all sorts of ways it doesn't mean it
really is
um I think it's not a bad test actually
because to talk to a gadget I mean I I
talked what was this this the machine's
name I forgotten the name there but she
was completely hopeless I tried to have
a conversation with her is that Sabina
or no that's a real person oh you say
you're saying you were conversing with a
oh okay so that's like Lisa or yeah
Elisa Sabine is very much real although
she's German so she's very very precise
yeah can I ask Roger a question about
that yeah of course Roger is it true
that you cannot simulate a Quantum
system I'm going the no cloning system
in which case that would kind of rule
out the simulation hypothesis of
Chalmers and everything I mean it's
pretty hard but you can now you can
simulate a Quantum system
well you can do it with a quantum
computer if you like that's that's what
they're for that's what they're good for
but um no that's a computational
procedure I mean that's okay the
Schrodinger equation
you can make it
you know simulate the schroding equation
but as Schrodinger pointed out that
isn't what real things do because they
collapse so you have to have collapse
part two
you couldn't simulate or
well that's the idea is that or is
something which involves a
non-computational process and that was
the idea
yeah
you can't see me uh the simulation
hypothesis is out the window
yes
I mean it's just that uh it's not true
in in this view this view is
that the or process is not computational
and some people say well what can I I
mean no mathematically you can produce
things which are not computational
they're theorems you can show they're
certain quite simple things are not
computational
this is hard for people who don't know
about these things to believe somehow
you could say oh you have a more
powerful computer and that would solve
the problem no there are certain things
which you can see even quite simple
problems
even things like um if you're given a
set of shapes which are made out of
square things called polyoma nerves
these are plain shapes made out of equal
squares glued together along their edges
and you're given a set of these shapes
and you want to know can you tile the
plane with those shapes can you
if you're not the whole plane with no
overlaps and no gaps
and whether you can or not is a
non-computational person there is no
algorithm
for doing this and I think people find
this hard to believe without knowing
about these things that you can have
problems like this for which there is no
algorithm the answer yes or no
is not algorithmic
so this and yet does that imply that
that you know there is something unique
about the conscious experience or does
that just reflect the limits of
mathematics in other words yes there are
things that are not computable but um
within the framework of mathematics
um but is that all conscious you know is
that all there is and I'm not getting
metaphysical here but but surely there's
more to being a conscious being than
being able to compute things I mean my
infant can't compute anything but it's
very conscious being not being able to
kill things
but no no no I always argued I can make
this very clear point I hope okay
but I'm only talking about one tiny bit
of what Consciousness does for us yes it
doesn't tell us anything about what the
perception of the color green is it
doesn't tell us anything about love it
doesn't tell you anything about
happiness it doesn't tell us anything
about pain but all these qualities which
which are to do with Consciousness it
doesn't tell you anything about any of
them except the one quality which is
aimed at which is that of understanding
and the only reason I'm focusing is that
that's because I can say something about
it and the Ironman is that whatever
understanding is and it requires
Consciousness just to understand
something is a conscious procedure that
that particular quality of Consciousness
is not a computational process right and
then I regard as a pretty clear argument
it doesn't tell you anything about the
most of the other things people talk
about when they talk about Consciousness
but they're not trying to argue in that
direction and try to argue in the
opposite direction to say that
the things that Consciousness can do
at least some of them are not
computational and so there must be
something else involved in them then
something you could put on a computer so
it's not something to put on the
computer you can have a very very
complicated computer which you can
answer all sorts of complicated
questions but it's still not conscious
very good so folks are asking a bunch of
questions I want to finish up in just a
few minutes it's getting late for sir
Roger
um so one of them is how do people get
involved in your work uh guys in
particular in uh you know a physics
student and maybe um you know a someone
in biology or Neuroscience neurobiology
with you Stuart so uh first of all Roger
do you have recommend career advice for
folks uh on the channel but I mean the
point of writing a book likely Road to
Reality was that it would guide people
into into science with relatively
harmlessly so they could
get some feeling for what these subjects
are like
without kind of getting too involved and
too many complicated calculations and
things like that
so
um
yeah
I think letting people excited about the
subject is the main thing
and if you get excited about a subject
then you're prepared to work hard
and that's the main main point is to say
yeah and uh Stuart what about you on
your side of things as uh as the you
know squishy wet representative as
opposed to the black hole and uh you
know experimental Bose Einstein
condensate represented
um what do you recommend somebody's
really fascinated by this they want to
get more involved how they do it as a
student or maybe as a layperson yeah the
well the field of quantum biology uh is
is coming out of the the closet so to
speak coming in out of the darkness and
uh because it was ridiculed by so many
uh seemingly knowledgeable people it's
impossible blah blah blah
um but now it's it's it's a it's a real
phenomenon we see you know
photosynthesis uh uh maybe bird
navigation uh Consciousness probably uh
even cognition in terms of binding The
Binding problem in neuroscience and uh
requires Quantum effects uh you know uh
brainwat gamma synchrony uh it's hard to
explain by nerve propagation and even
with a faptic transmission so Quantum
biology is becoming real and I think
it's going to open up a lot of a lot of
avenues and a lot of uh opportunities uh
in Pharmacology uh Quantum Optical
pharmacology and that sort of thing so
the people that have been involved with
the Templeton project here uh we're
forming a group uh and uh we'll be going
forward so you may have to sneak up on
it because you may you may come up
against a somebody who thinks it hasn't
gotten the word that it's not nonsense
which it was described after many years
but I think it's actually at the
Vanguard of of the future of
Neuroscience and uh you know
Neuroscience needs a revolution let me
let me say that the brain is a complex
computer of simple neurons it just
doesn't work and I think a better model
is a is a multi-scale hierarchy and
people go from neurons upwards into
networks of and then networks of
networks but also going downward and
we've identified 18 orders of magnitude
going down from the level of neurons
into the microtubule bundles
microtubules the aromatic the
tryptophans the electron dipoles and all
the way down eventually to Roger's
space-time geometry so um I think this
is going to be changing things and I
think Neuroscience needs a new paradigm
because the old one really doesn't work
um very good okay guys in the last
couple of minutes I want to do uh
something that I've done with Roger in
the past which is to ask a bunch of
existential questions I used to call
these the thrilling three they're all
based on Sir Arthur C Clarke's uh many
many laws but I never asked Stuart
because this is your first time solo
appearing or not solo appearing but
appearing on the podcast and I would be
remiss if I didn't ask you these
questions so I'm going to first ask uh
you both a question that I didn't ask
sir Roger and that has to do with
Arthur's
um Arthur's
um I believe it was his third law
actually
Asimov I think you think oh no no these
are uh Sir Arthur C Clark had all these
laws so one of which is uh any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable for magic we'll get to
that that's the first one yeah the first
one I want to ask you sir Roger and
Stewart but I I haven't asked Roger this
um Roger uh Rogers uh Arthur C Clarke
said that when a distinguished but Elder
elderly scientist states that something
is possible they are almost certainly
right when they state that something is
impossible they are very probably wrong
I want to ask you uh Roger and then you
Stuart
um what have you changed your mind about
recently uh you both are maybe not
elderly well Roger let's face it you're
you're almost middle age so that's maybe
not not uh elderly but um but how do you
react how how have you or what have you
changed your mind about if anything
recently
recently it depends you see since you
you say I'm a youngster so I can
multiply that but I have a fairly large
Factor uh she'd be almost 91. so um if
I'm allowed to go back about 20 years I
certainly had a big change of mind
so I mean I mean am I does that count
yeah it counts so what was it about what
was the change of heart about it's about
cosmology you see I used to believe like
everybody else that the origin of the
universe was the Big Bang
I had a lot of problem with it because
this this fundamental problem which has
to do is why is that
event so very strange and peculiar it's
very improbable
and then I formed a view which is how it
came above which is it's not the
beginning at all that it's the
continuation of what I call a previous
eon
and it's the remote future of that Eon
sort of compressed down into what we
think was the Big Bang and there are
many
observations now which seem to confirm
this Theory people seem to ignore it for
some strange reason
paper which came out two years ago now
and the monthly notices of the Royal
Astronomical Society as far as I'm aware
there is no paper of criticism of this
there are people which criticized the
previous version that was on the archive
but that had to be taken out down when
the actual article was published and in
this thing we claim there are these
spots or in the sky which we call
Hawking points or Hawking spots and
these are seen
and they're seen with great confidence
level
and
I I wouldn't have predicted those being
there without having this Theory and
they are they do seem to be there in the
observations
I'm not quite sure whether this is
answering your question or not well
saying it's um not exactly I mean the
the questions change your mind about it
but but I think I think it's fair to say
uh you know that that having ideas the
boldness of your ideas and having
conviction are is certainly an important
aspect of scientific success as I think
you know admitting mistakes or accepting
challenges etc etc so I guess with um
and we talked on your 90th birthday I
presented an update just for those of
you who are interested Stewart will send
me the link again later but we we had a
very fascinating conversation among
cosmologists and neuroscientists but on
when I spoke I spoke about the current
state of uh Research into Hawking points
I'll put a link to that somewhere below
eventually or above I don't know where
it's going to be floating around but um
but Roger have you ever thought about
um you know even more controversial
things I'm thinking about you know now
at least in the kind of zeitgeist in
America there's a lot of talk about the
existence of extraterrestrials and and
things like that have you ever
contemplated that you know standard
Orthodox scientific lore could be wrong
or or it might have a position uh when
it comes to the existence of
extraterrestrial intelligence or
technology
well I think I think it should be out
there the question is how far away
and there is this thing called the seti
program where people try and look for
this in very very distant galaxies you
might see get signals now the point of
view which
and I put forward in a paper was that if
you have this previous year thing which
I talked about you might get signals
from beings they probably would be have
to be gravitational wave signals because
to get through from the next it's a bit
hard to see how to do this and there are
ways but gravitational waves are
probably the most likely so you might
see in gravitational wave signals
evidence for some previous civilization
which would be quite possible I mean
could they use other signals like
neutrinos or would those suffer
um from degradation or it's a
possibility neutrino is another
possibility yes I think gravitational
wears the best bet
uh-huh okay very good okay yeah I never
asked you about that so it's good that
we got the chat about that
um Stuart I want to go back to you now
and ask you that same question uh you're
not elderly but um but you're
distinguished so I'd like to ask you
what have you changed your mind
say that again I am pretty elderly but
go ahead uh you know you remind me of
some of the guys I see surfing uh down
in in San Diego
um Stuart tell me what have you changed
your mind about if anything recently
well I used to think as other people do
that the brain is a computer and I think
instead as I said before it's more of a
multi-scale hierarchical system more
like a musical system in some sense I've
referred to it as a Quantum Orchestra uh
and because I think the computational
metaphor doesn't work because well it
works to a to a point but it treats
neurons as simple on off switches and
that's an insult to neurons and I think
you know if you go inside neurons
there's all this uh
interesting uh I hate to use the word
complex because I think complexity is
often the last Refuge of the bewilder
just saying it's complex and that
explains everything which I think is
wrong but you have all this this
structure these microtubules doing all
this interesting Quantum uh stuff and
Quantum computation uh reducing by or is
not the kind of competition I was uh
disillusioned with so uh I'd say that
one thing is that the brain is a
multi-scale hierarchical system more
like music than a classical computer ah
very good okay now I'm going to ask you
some of the questions I asked Roger
about uh many many times in the past and
his many appearances and I want to also
remind folks you can subscribe to my
channel uh for updates it will have
Sabina hasenfelder coming on and she'll
be live in the chat room on Tuesday uh
this will be the uh what is it the the
ninth I believe the day after Roger's
birthday um so join in and Roger
features prominently in her book which
is around here somewhere in my under
ground bunker it's quite quite
interesting and she does talk about
Consciousness and quantum mechanics as
we have discussed but if you join my
mailing list you'll get updates on all
these things and you may win a little
tiny bit of of space dust here's a
little tiny meteorite that I'm giving
away to the first hundred people that
join my mailing list at Brian
keating.com list so I'll put that right
can I say something about space dust
because I've been working with uh
planetary scientist Dante Loretta who
put this probe out is scooped up
carbonaceous material from the asteroid
yeah just bring it back and he's looking
for organic molecules and uh these these
polyaromatic hydrocarbons very similar
to the organic molecules in our bodies
and inside our microtubules uh are are
everywhere in space apparently including
uh Interstellar dust and there these uh
they have the aromatic rings and so
forth then uh
these may be the and they radiate
terahertz so they may be a form of uh An
Origin a source the origin of life and
Consciousness and Dante thinks that uh
origin of life and conscience are very
closely related and what about you
because since since we're here uh what
do you think about the existence of
extraterrestrial intelligence technology
are there people that uh could could
Advance this field uh Millennia by uh
just the mere existence of
extraterrestrial intelligence
well we have we've seen these these
images of these uh unidentified what do
they call it unidentified uh aerial
phenomena phenomena and uh they're
they're very interesting and uh I I
don't think you can just dismiss them as
as artifact or hallucination or or fake
and uh I heard one interesting talk that
when they they suddenly move and
accelerate there's no heat trail behind
them and and that they might have you
know this is more Rogers Area than mine
that they might have
their propulsion mechanism might have
something to do with with gravity or or
uh or bending space time or something
like that and uh and they also might be
some kind of meta material that's that's
changing changing shape and and whatnot
so I don't know I I probably said more
than I should about that but I think you
know
there there's probably a lot out there
and it just chosen not to communicate
with us and who can blame them because
uh there's a lot of problems there right
exactly okay next question that I ask
all my beloved guests uh has to do with
your
um I would say imminent future but not
too imminent hopefully uh when you
depart this Mortal coil at age 120 in
the biblical sense uh you will leave
this earth your material Goods will go I
don't know University of Arizona uh
you're one up for a wife and family I
don't know uh but where will your what
will be your your ideological Legacy
your ethical Legacy what would you like
to impart to all of humanity after you
leave this earth in hopefully not for
till 120 years old what ethics or wisdom
do you want to leave
oh that's for me that's for you yes I
asked Roger in the past uh he's welcome
to answer or he's welcome to rebut your
answer but that would be rude and he
would never do that
well first of all uh I I might disagree
with Roger about this but I I'm I'm not
ruling out afterlife because if
Consciousness is happening in the fabric
of space-time geometry uh then it and uh
I was asked this about near-death and
not about experiences many years ago and
I said well you know it could be that
the quantum information uh dissipates
the universe but stays entangled as a as
as some kind of entity and uh I I I
don't claim evidence for that I'm not
holding you know my own hopes for that
I'm not planning on it but I don't think
he can rule it out until we know uh what
Consciousness is in you know between the
ears we can't rule it out outside and I
think there's uh you know enough
evidence for for non-locality and in
Consciousness and this and that Roger
what do you think about the afterlife I
I haven't actually asked you that uh I
suspect you're uh not optimistic about
it but what are you what are your
thoughts directly
well to start with I'm certainly an
atheist yeah
yeah what when you say when I say an
atheist I mean I don't believe in any
religion I've ever seen
it doesn't mean that I'm um I'm I'm
agnostic if you like with regards to
the possibilities which are not
religious possibilities I mean
whether one's Consciousness can somehow
continue in some form the problem is
there if it did I can't imagine that you
carry any memories you see if if I for
example was someone else before I was
born what's the use of that because I
don't have any memory of that so if
there was some being who was me before I
came along
become me sort of loses its point in a
sense
so I don't quite see how that could work
there might be something else which is
completely beyond our understanding
since we know we know so little about
Consciousness despite
we know so little about it it's a bit
hard to pontificate on on what happens
to it after it gets blown up or
something
nuclear bomb or something you know
that's right it really happened
um so Stuart now I'm going to ask you a
question that's uh related to Arthur's
uh C Clarke's famous statement that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic and that is
um and that is basically what object or
Theory or Discovery in the history of
humanity to date is most worthy of being
preserved as sort of our most magical uh
uh accomplishment as a species something
that we put on a monolith that might
last for billions of years for these
potential aliens to find someday what
what do you think is the the thing that
human beings should have the most
Swagger about it doesn't have to be your
Discovery it could be some anything that
human beings have done what should we
brag about
well you know quantum mechanics is is
closest to Magic among among our side
that you know non-locality entanglement
uh over distance and time and uh uh
you know Roger brought together uh
general relativity consciousness
and quantum mechanics and in his recent
work on retroactivity he didn't talk
about it but he's added special
relativity because he uses special
relativity to come up with the fact that
that that has to be uh there has to be
this retroactivity it's kind of the uh
the motivation for it so
um I you know if if
it
Consciousness is uh you know
might be the answer to your question
because uh
it seems like magic in terms of
explaining it people have uh gone to the
extremes and saying that it will never
you know ideal not idealist what they
call them mysterians say we'll never
understand it's impossible it's like
expecting a fish to read a dictionary or
something like that but I don't think
that's true I think you know Roger is
way smarter than almost everybody and I
think he came up with this idea and uh I
think he's right and uh because it makes
the most sense now it could be wrong but
it's logical and and I think that would
be something that would stand uh forever
very good okay the last question and uh
Roger you're welcome to chime on to this
and this involves your past we've talked
about the future a couple times already
I want to ask both of you guys if you
could go back in time as I like to say
that the only way of of discovering the
limits of the possible is to venture
Beyond them into the pot into the
impossible that's the name of the
podcast I want to ask you guys both if
you could talk to your 20 year old self
and give him advice what would it be to
give him the confidence to go into the
impossible as you have done so I'll
start with Roger and then we'll go to
Stuart so Roger advice to your 20 year
old self what would you tell him right
now oh dear that's a hopeless question I
mean
um
you see I couldn't tell him to do what I
did because I didn't follow what I was
doing you see I was doing two
mathematics and I got tempted into
talking about physics and things so I
have no rational line which I followed
from when I was young
I there are a lot of accidental things
which happen to me one way or the other
and they could easily have done a
different thing
and I don't think there was any advice
that I
could have been given that would have
helped me one way or another I mean
maybe advice when it comes to emotional
things and if we're talking about
science here I think then then I really
have no answer
some suggestions in the other direction
but I'm not going to tell you right
and lastly Stuart what would you tell
your 20 year old self if you could go
back in time and violate all sorts of
causality Etc yeah well I've made a lot
of mistakes in my life and I would
correct them uh if I could but as far as
my career choice and and the uh what I'm
you know uh medicine studying
consciousness
being fortunate enough to meet and work
with Roger and developing this theory
has been a tremendous experience for me
and I've got number one I've gotten to
see the world I've been all over the
world many times and and uh
you meet the most interesting people
including you and and especially Roger
who has been uh you know one of the
great things in my life has been his
colleague and friend and so that part of
my life I wouldn't change many other
things
all right well everybody this has been
phenomenal fun uh Roger happy early
birthday Stuart enjoy Canada uh until
you come back home it's still sweltering
down here in uh in the southwest uh
everybody tune in on Monday uh for uh
submit your questions to Nick Bostrom
you can find them on my community
Channel or on my Twitter account Dr
Brian Keating you can find Stuart we'll
put links to Stuart and Roger in the uh
in the video description and all their
amazing accomplishments I wish you guys
all the best stay tuned on Tuesday the
9th we have an interview live with
Sabina hasenfelder she'll be in the room
you can snark out with me and she so
guys thank you guys so much enjoy the
rest of your day Roger good night and
happy birthday my friend thank you for
inspire hiring millions of people around
the world
thank you happy birthday Roger thank you
Brian